this is jocko podcast number 177
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
a few days later
when i walked downstairs to go work out
i saw uncle jake's bag packed up sitting
by the door
that's when it hit me
the summer was almost over and uncle
jake was leaving again
i went out to the garage to work out and
uncle jake was already there
last workout with me for the summer he
said with a smile
i can't believe it's over already summer
always goes by so fast i told him
yes it does uncle jake said quietly
and life does the same thing
i wasn't sure what uncle jake meant by
that so i asked what
you'll see mark
he said life goes by quickly
like a summer day
it never seems that way when you're
young but when you get a little older
you'll see life goes by fast
so don't waste any time
you don't get a second chance
uncle jake stood for a minute looking at
me with a serious face
then he gave me a little smile and said
speaking of wasting time let's stop
wasting time and get this workout done
he jumped up on the pull-up bar grabbed
hold
and started knocking them out
and that
is a little excerpt
from the last chapter in a new book
the latest edition in the series way the
warrior could kid book three the
subtitle the book is where there is a
will
and i wrote that part of the book
because i wanted to let kids know as
early as possible that that is the truth
that life goes by
like a summer day
and the life is short
and if you remember
when you were a kid and summer you get
out of school for the summer and it
seems like you have all the time in the
world it seems like summer vacation is
going to last forever
and then
all of a sudden it's blurred you look up
and
as soon as summer vacation has started
all of a sudden
it's over
that's what i remember about summers
and that's the truth and that's what
life is like
about
a year and a half ago
september 29 2017
and september 29th is saint michael's
day that's the day that
mikey monsoor was killed in ramadi in
2006. so on september 29th 2017 i
woke up and i was thinking about that
and i was thinking about mikey and
later that day
i think i was actually heading up to
rosecrans national cemetery where mikey
is buried and i was gonna go
and visit mikey's grave and while i was
on my way up there
i got a call and
i found out that
one of my
mentors one of the guys
that raised me in the seal teams
a guy named
master chief mike fakady
he had died
and he had been
in a pretty hardcore battle with lung
cancer
even though he was a non-smoker even
though he was a triathlete even though
he worked out all the time
he got this form of lung cancer and
originally the doctors told him he was
going to live for six months
but that was in i think 2012
he had retired in 2001.
and i sitting there thinking about
faculty and actually
btf tony talked about him called him faq
when he was on the podcast because we
all called him fak
but i remembered
just a bunch of different things about
fact and one of the things that i
remembered was i had
come back from my third deployment so
this is in the 90s back in the day
and
i had done my third deployment and i had
been moved into the training department
at seal team one so instead of doing a
work up and going on deployment the way
the teams used to be set up you would
you would go into training cell and the
team trained itself
the the training department at seal team
one trained the platoons at seal team
one later it became that we had a big
centralized training command that's what
i ran before i got out before i retired
i ran that the tradet on the west coast
but it used to be each team had their
own training cell and that's how you
would
train platoons to get ready for their
deployments
and of course
nobody really wanted to be in training
cell because it meant you couldn't go on
deployment and that's why you joined the
seal teams is to go on deployment
and for whatever reason we in a bunch of
us from my platoon that i'd gone through
buds with
a bunch of guys we dug all done three
platoons that kind of we all kind of got
thrown into training cell at the same
time
and we'd been in there for a couple days
i mean maybe less than a week we come
back from deployment we get put in a
training cell
and i kind of forget what happened but a
couple guys that were getting ready to
deploy
got hurt
in fact it might have been guys that got
hurt as soon as they got over there
maybe they didn't go on deployment the
guys that went replaced us
all of a sudden they needed a couple
guys and at quarters in the morning
that's when
at seal team one they used to have
quarters in the morning where you all
stand up and line up sort of like your
typical military formation everyone
would kind of line up and
buy platoon and the platoons would all
report in that was an old school
team one deal right there
and then if there was any important
announcements to make then the
announcements would get made and then
everyone would go about their day
well the announcement that got made that
morning
was
hey we need two guys to go on deployment
is there anyone here that feels like
going on deployment or can go on
deployment
and of course
it's a big deal right to just pick up
and go and leave for six months
and
it was
actually my roommate at the time who had
been my roommate who i went through buds
with and who i did three platoons with i
went through seal tactical training with
with him
and we were actually roommates that
entire time so we we were tight he's my
brother
and when they asked this question of hey
is there anybody here that can go on
deployment like tomorrow or the next day
and basically out of the whole team it
was
him and me we raised our hand said yeah
hey we'll go cause
at that time
you know we were just single team guys
we didn't have anything else we
literally had nothing else you could put
our whole world into two cruise boxes
and we could ship anywhere in the world
we didn't care we had no attachments we
had didn't care about anything so of
course we raised our hands
and as soon as our hands went up
master chief faculty gave us a glare
because he was the guy that was in
charge of training cell
so he gave us a glare
and
quarters ended and he goes he said hey
won't you guys come upstairs and talk to
me real quick
and i was thinking okay we must have
done something wrong and sometimes you
didn't know what you did wrong but i
me and my buddy we figured we'd done
something wrong so we went up there
and actually actually now i think about
we he brought us into the chiefs mess
and we were like e4s or e5s at the time
and so getting pulled into the chief
chief's mess i'd never been in there
before
and
i was like scared thinking what did i i
thought i did something wrong i thought
that i left a trail of some crime i'd
committed and now we're getting busted
and we get up there and basically he
reamed us out and he says listen
you guys need to be in training cell and
he was making great points i didn't
recognize that time he said look if you
want to be professionals if this is
where you're going to learn a lot we
need good guys to be teaching the rest
of the platoons that's why you're in
here you're not going on deployment shut
up
and i'm pulling your names out of the
hat and they'll find two other people
that can go we'll send some new guys
over there it doesn't matter
so that's what it was that was
this little story it was funny because
you know we were
it was just funny from multiple reasons
when i thought back about just the fact
that you're in a point in your life
i think i was probably like 23 or 24
years old and just just think about
right now if someone says hey can you
just leave for six months tomorrow
i mean there's not too many people that
can just pull up and do that
so there's that there's the fact that
you know faculty was bringing us into
the chiefs mess and we were all nervous
about that
and then the fact that you know faculty
what he was actually doing was trying to
look out for us and trying to look out
for our careers and trying to look out
for the seal team he was trying to do
the right thing and it was was one of
those
one of those
little stories and there's just all
these little stories like that
that that make up that whole era
of
my life that whole time as a young
enlisted guide seal team on it's this
whole
bunch of
memories
and
when he died i got this feeling that
those
[Music]
memories those
those days
are over
like they're gone
because
at least partially because when fact was
around part of those memories are facts
memories like only he could tell us what
he was thinking at that time
and
when he dies
when he died then
those memories are gone
and
rick i can't ask him about him i can't
go and
have a beer with him and
talk about that time and hear his side
of it like no they're they're not here
they're gone
and
as i was you know again going up to see
mikey monsoor
at rosecrance
and continue to think about that and
thinking about
the memories that mikey had and
how those are going
but i didn't have too much time to dig
into those thoughts because the next
morning
september 30th 2017 that's when i got
word that the delta platoon commander
my brother
seth stone had
died as well
and all kinds of
memories
died with him
i mean i got my half of them
but it's half
it's incomplete conversations
and jokes and guitar jams
and then on top of those i'd get little
like seth was
incredibly smart
and he'd give me little ideas little
thoughts
but only the beginning because there's
millions of things to talk about you
think you got your whole life to
to consider those things
but you don't
and i get that
we can try and
talk about them or we can try and write
them down and we can do everything in
our power to
to try and hang on to those things
but the fact of the matter is you you
can't
you can't
preserve them
in their true
form
it's just gone
and as i
thought about that and as i continue to
think about that and try and figure out
what can we do
if we can't
preserve
these
memories
then what can we do
and i think
the best thing that we can do is try and
make more
try
and make more
make more memories
so
so keep in mind what uncle jake said
life goes by
like a summer day
so you better take advantage of it
and you best make yourself
some memories along the way
and with that
echo yes it's been a little while since
we
did some q a yes sir
what do you got
we got some questions from the interwebs
all right we'll go into it first
question
what do you do when the boss always says
we can't
but doesn't offer logical and reasonable
alternatives
to make positive forward changes should
one just do what they think is best and
not listen to the boss
uh okay
first of all what we want to do is we
want to support the boss
we want to build a relationship
with the boss what's the best way to
support the boss which the best way to
build relationship is to be a performer
be a performer inside the box right that
the boss has said you can't do this you
can't do that cool we're gonna do the
best we can inside the box
and once you do that once you once you
actually
once you actually
are a performer
then you have leverage then you can
actually talk about a different
way of doing things you can bring up a
legitimate idea to the boss and they may
well they have a better chance of
listening to you
so that's what you got to do you got
gotta play the game a little bit you
gotta you gotta become a performer you
gotta do
what it is the way they want it done
to the best of your ability be
successful with it
and then once you've built up some clout
and some relationship
and maybe a little political capital
then you can present
a new idea and when you present the new
idea have the facts lined up don't go in
there half cocked
and
present your idea and hopefully gets
cleared now that's one that's section a
section b is
do you got to make things happen
sometimes yep
and depending on how
like
it's that whole thing of
it's better to beg forgiveness than ask
for permission that's a real that's a
it's it's it's a it's a tool it's
definitely a tool
if you abuse it you're gonna get crushed
if it's one of those things where
the the boss has told you not to do
something and you decide well i'm gonna
do it anyways and i'll just beg for
forgiveness they actually told you not
to do it that's not where you're
supposed to use that tool yeah that's
just that's just that's just unsat right
unset
if it's something where well i kind of
suspect that the boss might not want it
this way but you know what
chances are it's going to go in my
direction and chances are it's going to
be beneficial and chances are the boss
might not even found out and if the boss
does find out
this isn't something that they've ever
declared hostile on right yeah
so
you'll be okay in that situation to
to beg for forgiveness but don't abuse
that tool and then what you do is you
start if when you're inside the hey i'm
going to beg for forgiveness then you
can start actually doing something and
developing a standard operating
procedure that makes sense and then once
you get it solidified you go to the boss
and say hey boss we've been doing this a
different way i want to let you know i
want to show you what we've been doing
because we you know you know boss we
never really had a specific way of
getting this done and i know some other
people did it like this and some people
did it like that we came up with a
methodology i actually wrote the whole
thing out for you so you can see exactly
what we're doing boom who's gonna say no
to that plus it's been successful 80
times boom we're good
so
so that's what you want to do that's
pretty pretty straightforward don't
don't just straight disobey the boss
unless the boss is telling you do
something that's going to get someone
killed or illegal or whatever
but if they're just have a different
idea or something just go with it
execute it become a good performer and
then once you have that relationship
built you'll have all kinds of influence
over your boss i always had crazy
influence over my bosses i don't want to
sound i don't say in an arrogant way
it wasn't like i was manipulating my
bosses but my boss is like i was honest
with my bosses and they i did good work
and so when i said hey boss
is are we sure we should do it this way
they'd be like well what do you think
yeah well here's what i think and then
we'd get done so
pretty straightforward yeah
pretty straightforward yeah that asking
for forgiveness thing it's a risky move
it's not a risky move but sometimes it's
a great move yeah if you kind of like
how you said like don't abuse it where
you know there's there's levels to it
yeah where there's like little things 32
levels
so like if you if there's one that's
like how you said like he told you not
to do something and this goes for like
anyone like anyone you're dealing with
like even your friends kind of thing you
know where they if you know for a fact
that they don't want you to do it so
that's why you'd prefer not to ask for
permission because you know they're
going to say no but you know it's like
right you shouldn't do that and you know
that yeah but if it's the kind where
it's like
i can see
why he'd want to do it maybe this way or
maybe not even necessarily want to do
this way because maybe he doesn't see
the benefits that we see right now but
and he's close-minded he's you know he
has that reputation so let's let's sort
of do it you said successfully you know
kind of thing so and then that's on the
other side of the spectrum you know but
some people men they'll just like take
it to level five or whatever and be like
oh yeah they're gonna hate this but it's
better to ask for forgiveness and
permission because that's a guarantee no
and forgiveness at least i can give but
probably you're gonna damage the
relationship if you do that stuff then
you're gonna get tightened down on
yeah like a step backwards yeah oh yeah
man it's true don't let that happen
don't let that happen next question
i'm the youngest leader in my firm's
history
i try and implement extreme ownership
and default aggressiveness in my team
being so young some of my elder
subordinates sometimes dismiss my
directives how do i lead those people
effectively
okay so
i actually hate when i get this question
or questions like this because it it
means that i've screwed up
that's what it means i don't like to
screw up but when i see a question like
this
it means that somebody has
misinterpreted the message a little bit
they haven't read the dichotomy
leadership for sure in my opinion
because if you read the dichotomy of
leadership you'll see that extreme
ownership and default aggressive are
supposed to be balanced
and so that's what's going on here you
got someone that's like you know what
i'm going to take extreme ownership hey
we're doing this my way this i'm the
boss i'm a leader
and that's just horrible and everyone
hates you so bro
you're young they don't hate you because
you're young
they're not mad at you because you're
inexperienced they don't dismiss you
because
um because you are
a decade younger than that's not why
it's happening
it's happening because
you are lacking humility you haven't
built up any relationship with these
people you haven't built up any
leadership capital with them you haven't
asked them how they think they should do
things you haven't asked them what
they've been doing for the last 22 years
while you were going to
middle school
right
so
come in be humble the the best way to
gain respect from people this is what's
hard to do this is hard to understand
you want people to respect you
ask them a question listen to what they
have to say
listen to their opinion if they come up
with a good plan use their plan
the worst way to gain respect from
people is to go in and demand respect
from people is to go in and say i'm i'm
implementing default aggressively you've
not heard of that you've never read
extreme ownership have you i'll tell you
what that's the way we're doing it here
i'll get you a copy so you can read up
and get on board with my program
these are all bad
so i'm not trying to say you sound just
like that but you might sound something
like that and you don't need to be too
far off that so
appreciate that you're getting after it
but what you need to get after more is
some balance be humble listen to the
team listen to what they have to say ask
for their input follow their input when
you can that's a little black belt move
it's a little black belt but it's
actually a blue belt move
but blue belt purple belt move like hey
my team gives me input i listen to them
we actually you know hey echo how do you
think which i think we should attack
this target from the north okay sounds
good why don't we roll with that that's
a blue belt move man
what's it what's a white belt move
negative no the white belt moves like
hey echo we're doing this we're
attacking this target from the south
you've got any questions
and you're like well i think i could
from the north might be a little bit
better that might be what you think but
that's not what we're doing plus i'm in
charge because i got ownership of this
whole thing yeah and i'm i'm default
aggressive so do what i said
so don't be that guy man try and back
off a little bit
try and form
as a leader you should be looking at
like one of your primary goals if not
your primary goal
is to form a relationship with your team
with the people on your team yeah
so get it done i remember in jiu jitsu
one time greg mcintyre
yes
he uh
trained
he uh he was teaching a move and the
move that he was teaching he uh
apparently got from me
and so he was teaching this move or
whatever and uh you know sitting there
we're all and he
was teaching he thought he had
way better than i could teach like yeah
way better in fact he taught it i simply
probably could not teach this move and
he uh and after he was done he was like
hey echo does this move really good to
the class acquisition echo do you have
anything to add to the move
and i was like oh i
no i don't i don't remember if i did i
don't think i did but just that feeling
you know
he included me in it you know man it was
so empowering you know even though it
was you know in in his mind and actually
thinking back and in my mind like that
that was kind of my move you know yeah
what move was it it was a it was a guard
pass move okay the one i always do to
you
um
depends on what you mean by always
yeah but nonetheless like just how you
say like how you ask their input kind of
thing it's like you include them in the
things and just it's not just asking it
it's actually receiving it and
implementing it that's that's the that's
the key that's the closure of the move
man yeah that's the closure of the move
bro talk about like a feeling and
granted me and greg are good friends
anyway but i'm just saying like you can
imagine that situation how the how
anyone would feel when you especially if
you're older than this little young buck
who does he think he is and he comes to
you you're like oh hell yeah okay this
guy knows like you know we can we can do
this together you know you really get
that feeling i would imagine anyway
that's what you want to do mr youngest
leader in your firm's history dan
congrats on that yeah congrats on it
you're getting after it what got you
there
may not get you to the next level what
got you there might have been like being
aggressive and making things happen and
stepping up that's cool
but if you piss off everyone in your
department
that's not going to work out good for
you they'll start to undermine you
they'll sabotage you so you gotta be
careful
check that's what i mean okay is there a
possibility that everyone in the
department you got put in there to
straighten things out that's a different
question
that's a different question let me tell
you something else when you're getting
when people are dismissing what you're
saying that's a horrible sign
one of the leadership books that we
covered
the rule was don't give commands that
you that that aren't going to be
followed
because every time you give a command
that that you know isn't going to be
followed
that's not going to work out good for
you it's reinforcing the fact that no
one needs to listen to you
so don't don't be giving
orders that are being dismissed if
somebody doesn't do something you go hey
man i know that
i might have come across a little wrong
when i was talking to you about you know
getting this done this product just part
of this task done
and i see it's still not done is there
is there some support that you need for
me is there some help that you need for
me because this is important i probably
didn't do a good job of explaining why
it's important but it's actually
connected to this larger project that
we're doing over at headquarters and
this is our part of the task and i don't
think i explained that very well but do
you need anything else for me to to
maybe move this along you can't just
allow things to be
for you to talk to for you to give
directions and they just get blown off
yeah like that's not good and what i'm
not saying is oh you blow off my order
now i'm going to go high order on you
right
that's not what i'm saying yeah
yeah that makes sense too because man if
i if i had a boss who i was i was primed
to dismiss any of his directives yeah
and it happened and it happened
successfully like i dismissed it and
there was really no real repercussions
oh you better believe i'm picking and
choosing what i'm following and by the
way
he's testing the envelope anyways he's
testing to see
you know what he can get away with
because he sees your young
young buck running in here thinks he's
going to tell me what to do watch this
they're not going to listen to you okay
cool now if you fly off the handle and
go nuts you know what you'll get them to
do it immediately yeah and then guess
what you're going to get undermined
you're going to get usurped you're going
to get they're going to have the project
fail just so they can get rid of you
they're going to laugh at you
yeah that's bad as
you're getting walked out by the hr
department
so you got to be careful man you got to
be careful
that's what i'm saying balance these
things out balance extreme ownership get
the book dichotomy leadership that's
what it's about
it's about being balanced
cool next question jaco what do you do
when people treat you like a doormat
and then when you finally put your foot
down they lose their minds
i try to be agreeable
but there's a limit
when i stand my ground people are act
shocked any advice yeah so this is
actually kind of the same thing right
you need to be balanced because what's
happening with this dude i assume
is that
sitting around
getting
getting like a pushover like a doormat
people are kind of walking all over and
then all of a sudden he does a instant
180 and goes
puts his foot down right
and now you think that they're gonna do
a 180. you think that they're gonna say
oh sorry i didn't mean to oh sorry echo
i didn't i didn't know that that
offended you i'm sorry no when you do
that they're like what's wrong with you
bro you just started tripping yeah yeah
you're freaking out over nothing so of
course when you stand there ground
they're gonna be shocked right which is
what you're saying happen this is like
no surprise at all so what you need to
do is
is you got to draw the line a little bit
earlier but without going nuts and i
think i got a good example of how you do
this okay let's say you got a dog
and the dog is like
kind of mellow and happy and just
doesn't just all good
and then like all of a sudden you know
you're walking by the dog one day and
rob it bites you on the arm
like like big time yeah
big time
how do you feel about that dog
yeah bad i don't like that that's bad
that dog's getting put down yeah right
yes
this dog let's say it bit one of your
kids oh yeah that dog's getting put down
okay so that's that's what this guy is
doing
all acting all
like everything's like nothing bothering
me and all of a sudden biting people
right
think about what a dog like a normal dog
does what a normal dog does is it's if
it starts getting offended a little bit
or starts getting problems it's it like
stands up a little bit right and then
it's gonna it's gonna growl
now that's an indicator so even a kid
even a child knows
i don't know what age but pretty young
kids know that a growling dog is a is is
a warning what else do dogs do dogs show
their teeth
that's another warning like hey that's
another line in the sand
and and barking right because you have
to bark
and i mean a dog barks at you when a dog
barks you it's got your attention it's
growling at you you know what's going to
happen next if you keep doing whatever
it is you're doing right you need to
back away from that dog
now if you did if the dog did all those
things to you and then it bit you
you you'll still be mad at it but you at
least know that you kind of had it
coming right
right yes sir yes so
so there you go that's what this dude
needs to do a little bit of he needs to
learn
how to growl a little bit
how to bark a little bit how to show
your teeth how to just stand up posture
correct because there's you know a dog
if you know dogs at all dogs have a
posture
and they have a posture their ears are
down and their their their tails down
when when they get fired up boom ears
are up
they're on alert their back is they get
the cackles can stand up and everything
that means like okay that's that's even
before growling that's happening alert
so this dude needs to learn how to come
to an alert and improve his pot increase
his posture in those moments
not when it's getting too far
but like when someone
when somebody gives you a little jab
you know you can't bite them
you got to give a little growl yeah back
him off a little bit you know and again
this is
i don't know you you know so it's hard
for me to say some people just have a
hard time
dealing with when people harass them
because i think the best thing to do
when somebody makes fun of me
is just to like be like yeah good one
you know like
because you know just like we were
talking about before we started this
podcast
if i let you know that whatever you just
said to me bothers me bro i can expect
you to just keep getting after that
thing until i snap
right yes so you got to be careful you
don't want to be
all hyper sensitive the other thing to
remember is man
when people are making fun of you it's
not like they hate you most of the time
yeah
you know it's it's not that big of a
deal like people talk smack to each
other
right people talk smack to each other
and and i guarantee this is this is a
good way to think about it
if someone talks smack to you
if you if and then you both leave let's
say it's at work you go home the other
person that was talking smack goes home
you go home you're thinking about it
that person that was talking smack
didn't think about it one millisecond
after he left the office he didn't care
he's not sitting there thinking about
you he's not thinking like man
oh man i'm really glad i told him
you know
he had a funny looking eyebrows that was
awesome i can't believe how weird his
eyebrows are like i mean that's like
he's not doing that right he's not even
thinking about it he just went home he's
carrying all his life carry on with your
life don't get all tied up about what
these other people are thinking of you
it's not that big of a deal no one's
sitting around thinking about it's it's
a it's a perception that we have that
the whole world revolves around us and
that people are sitting around thinking
about us all the time it's like they're
not thinking about you all the time they
don't care they're they're at home
there's not too many people that are
actually thinking about you all the time
especially if they're making fun of you
like they're they're not thinking about
that all the time so just relax take a
wrap off
and just
you know
try and have a little bit less tension
and you know and try and learn to growl
a little bit or at least protect your
space a little bit and these are kind of
contrary contradictory things that i'm
saying one of them's like hey laugh at
it the other one's like kind of learned
to growl a little bit
i would say first the first method is
better the first method is like hey just
laugh it off don't worry about it these
people aren't thinking about you they
don't care
probably it's like when we had jordan
peterson and he was talking about his
friend lunch bucket right lunch bucket
yeah the guy that worked and as soon as
everyone realized that it bothered him
that they called him lunch bucket
everyone just called him lunch bucket
and then they he quit because he
couldn't handle it so don't be if you
would if someone calls you lunch bucket
you know how cool yeah my mom makes a
good sandwich mom makes a pretty good
sammy you know
and then boom you break out the lunch
bucket
like you know go with it no no factor
yeah if you start freaking out about
this stuff it's going to drive you crazy
so yeah man so be careful
don't freak out about stuff
if you have to learn to stand your
ground a little bit but don't just start
snapping like a dog
like a rabid dog
yeah that that that is a good little
escalation that example yeah escalating
you know the dog thanks decent because i
mean getting treated like a doormat that
could look like a bunch of different
things you know it's teasing that seems
like the obvious one or whatever but
you know that could be a lot of stuff
yeah that could be like hey grab me some
coffee yeah right sometimes people just
do that because
you haven't ever said to them like you
know like hey man are you ever gonna get
me coffee what's up you know you just
make a joke about the same thing yeah
exactly like dealing with it like as a
you know something bothers you so and i
could see this may be happening because
every once in a while like you know you
kind of run into these scenarios where
like someone does something that you um
you don't really like or you don't i
don't appreciate the way they treated me
right there during that scenario and it
sort of always happens but it's too
small to make a big deal out of it at
that time and when you're a agreeable
person you're just like all right yeah
i'm gonna essentially i'm gonna let it
slide whatever you know but it happens
again then again but i'm agreeable i'm
letting it slide haha maybe i'll even
laugh it off whatever so to the other
person they're just like whatever
they're just like you said they're not
thinking about it they're just going
about their business and they're getting
a laugh here and there which instantly
gets forgotten and whatever they keep
going about their business no no
no factor
meanwhile in my head i'm like man
i'm getting tired of this i'm straight
up getting tired so it happens one day
maybe i got a little less sleep that day
or something one teeny tiny thing i'm
flying off the handle hey i don't
appreciate this and this night you do
you always do it and they're like dude
even if i did i didn't get any so then
you get this little reputation people
act shocked as the guy says you know
when i stand my ground it's the other
person is kind of like why are you
standing your ground right now it
doesn't make sense like even if i did
remember all the times i've done this
you were laughing the whole time like it
it doesn't compute it was funny now that
now that i think i think about times in
my life like when i was younger
and someone would stand their ground on
me or whatever and i'd be like what are
you talking about i'd be the exact
person that you're talking about saying
what are you talking about man like i
have no idea what you're talking about
yeah why are you freaking out right now
yeah and they're like you always say
stuff like this and maybe i'd put
together like okay maybe i do make
whereas now that i'm older if someone
was to freak out like that on me i would
instantly recognize thinking to myself
like you know what i probably do things
that i shouldn't i probably oh yeah i
kind of ride this person and that's why
they're freaking out right now yeah a
little bit more aware yeah of my impact
yeah
and but in a way you sort of had to
i mean i'm sure you've sort of you're
sort of familiar with this you know even
like painting that picture it's like
it's obvious you're familiar with this
you know but when it's happening to you
you're kind of not but then if you have
to go go back and do like some
investigation of your whole like
relationship with the person to
understand okay now i see how that could
have been interpreted back last year and
then maybe three months ago and then
maybe last week and then like right now
okay i mapped it you know then it it but
it doesn't compute naturally you know so
yeah if you do that the escalating dog
yes thing it'll it'll be more clear i
think yeah and you can only be an
escalated dog only escalate the dog
scenario if you can't just have a good
dime with it and relax and not worry
about it yeah which is the primary goal
yes but being treated like a doormat
like i said like if you know how like
people are just so you know people
people pleaser type of person like in a
relationship or something okay like um
you know like uh
i don't know it's i can't think of an
example but you have a movie reference
that's very pathetic
actually
actually i can think of your page
anyway if you're like a people pleaser
and you do everything for you know and
then they don't do it back you know kind
of thing like oh yeah you let your you
know husband or wife or whatever you let
them go out every saturday just because
they want to they want to go play poker
or you know one of these things that
what's the common thing that they do and
they do and they come back later
but no well it'll be way worse than that
it'll be just total like whatever you
need or want you got it and then like
the one time they say hey i want to go
shopping on this they'd be like oh
shopping well you got to do this you got
to do the you know like that kind of
where it's like a disproportionate like
relationship you know kind of thing
like that can i can see how it can go
down with those types of relationships
you know like being you can't just laugh
those things off no in life you know you
you do have to do the escalation
like hey that's a little bit more
serious yeah yeah true
next question
hey jocko i'm a business owner in the
beginning stages of merging with another
company the other company doesn't know
much about
what we do
but has the sales and marketing
marketing we need
just at a conference with uh just at a
conference call with them and it didn't
go well they're wanting to change the
pay structure for our contractors as
well as change how we build our
customers all the all for the benefit of
money
cha-ching yeah save some money on that
one is it not a good idea to have
have the primary mission be about money
and more so on the success of the
customer or is it good to be money
motivated i i have and enjoy all your
books oh you know well that's cool i
think any advice would be helpful so
that means you've read the dichotomy of
leadership i hope
because it this is the answer of the day
need to be more balanced okay so
if you're money hungry right which is
what this is sounding like if you're
money hungry correct if you're money
hungry you're going to cut corners on
product
the product is going to be
weak or or low quality
you're going to do wrong by the customer
right because when you when you get a
chance to you know the customer the
customer placed an order a double order
by accident they click the click thing
twice
and and they still have to pay that
restocking fee you know or whatever like
whatever the thing is right you treat
customers like that and they're gonna go
okay well we don't really want to shop
with you anymore and you end up with a
bad reputation and the quality is low
and no eventually you have no more
business that's what's gonna happen so
so no we can't go
hardcore
money grubbing just
that's our that's our focus
other end of the spectrum
is hey we're paying our contractors too
much is that possible yes it's possible
you're giving your customers too much
you're giving them too good of a price
point
and guess what's now going to happen
same thing you're going to not have a
business anymore so the one you have you
your business goes out of business
because you're because you don't have
any business anymore because you've
treated your customers bad and the
contractors don't want to work with you
so you have you end up shutting down
this one's opposite you're you everyone
loves you you just don't have any money
so you're going out of business
so there has to be some
balance you have to find the right
balance that's what every company is
trying to do
now i would say
that you would where you want to lean
and this is probably what you're
thinking
you want to lean toward
taking care of the customer you want to
lean toward
giving the contractors good value for
their work
you want to lean toward
high quality the reason you want to lean
towards those things is those are all
long term strategic
payoffs right what's the short term the
short terms take advantage of the
customers the short term is screw over
the contractors the short term has put
out low quality stuff we make good
profit this quarter yeah yeah
but it's a it's a short term win it's a
long time long term loss so that's why i
would say lean don't go out of control
you can't go out of control in that
direction
but you can lean towards that direction
now as far as the new company the merger
and all this stuff
get it i get it
here's what's going to happen what you
need to go and build good relationships
with those people the new company they
need to be your best friends
because
if you build relationships with them
then you can have influence over these
points
if you have an antagonistic relationship
and you're the new guy or whatever like
oh yeah the new company you you think
they don't you're saying that they what
does he say they don't know what we do
right
what do you think they think they think
you don't know what they do they're
thinking you know what you don't even
hey you guys make good might make good
product but you can't sell anything we
got sales and we got marketing we could
sell anything
we don't care what it looks like we
don't care what the quality is that's
what they're thinking yeah
so you need to form a relationship with
them because i will tell you with their
sales and marketing if you're making a
good product that's how we get the big
time win but if you have an antagonistic
relationship with them
uh it'll all fall apart and you won't
have any influence at all and they'll be
like you don't even know what you're
talking about dude we're just gonna jack
the price even more and we're gonna
undercut our contractors we're gonna get
contractors competing with each other
they're gonna hate each other they're
gonna hate us but it doesn't matter look
at our bottom line
so
build some relationships there
next wish
i'm conflicted about where my loyalty
lies
i have a wife and two children but i
recently took a job within federal law
enforcement and based on my prior
tactical experience
i'll be given the opportunity to attend
a two-week selection for a position as
an operator on a full-time tactical team
that will most certainly pull me away
from my family my heart is in the right
place i know this level of sacrifice is
needed in order to keep evil at bay
however i believe every father feels
that obligation to be at home to raise
the children
and i'm learning that balancing duty
responsibility loyalty commitment to
family to country is hard and maybe
impossible
all right so
oh yeah he goes on to say that i know
you have made this decision yourself
yeah and i would say to this dude um
actually you are the only person that
can make this decision and
you're right i did make that decision i
did 20 years and
i at the end of 20 years decided to
prioritize my family over the military
and over my own desires too
because believe me the selfish thing is
just keep getting after it
but also what's important i was not good
at balancing right i've i ranked and
prioritized the teams above my family
the whole time i was in and not everyone
does that some people are much better at
balancing than i did and that's how they
do 30 and 32 years and 34 years and 27
years they they figure out how to
balance that better than i did
and so it sounds like you're even
raising this question indicates to me
that you probably have a decent chance
of being able to be better at balancing
than i do
so
there's that the other thing i would say
is you say that the
being an operator and full-time tactical
team will most certainly pull me away
from my family
i would research that a little bit
you know because sometimes
when you get to a little higher level
you have more flexibility and you might
you might actually have time to spend
with your family it might be a little
bit different maybe you're on call
whereas normally you wouldn't be on call
the novice on your own call but you're
while you're on call you're at least you
know you're you might be doing you might
have more family time i don't know
i can tell you that you know sometimes
depending on the way you look at it
you know if you look at the special
operations community versus
the conventional community and it just
depends on the units depends on a lot of
things but sometimes you know the
conventional forces go on a you know
16-month deployment to iraq
and that's a long time some special
operations units going on four-month
deployments and they come home now they
now they might do more of those over
their career
but again that's something you need to
you need to find out the facts you need
to talk to someone that's on that team
and say hey listen here's what's going
on i got two sons they wrestle
and they do jiu jitsu and i like to go
to those tournaments what's our schedule
like how is it gonna be you know
and then you kind of you can make a
better assessment i wouldn't just assume
that
the
tactical team has a busier schedule i
could be wrong i could be completely
wrong
what what you're probably the assumption
you're making which is a decent
assumption is that when you're part of a
part of an elite tactical team you're
gonna have to input more time it's gonna
it's gonna it's gonna mean more to you
and you're gonna be like okay i need to
train more
i'm gonna tell you should train more no
matter what position you're in right you
need to be training as much as you can
you need to be staying sharp
so i would do some research on that
and then i would also consider this
men have been leaving their families
so they could go and fight evil since
the beginning of time
whether it was they were going out to
fight the lions
or whether they were going out to fight
some or going to invade other countries
or go and find treasure or whatever
whatever they were doing people have
been doing it even world war ii guys
left and there was no guarantee that
they were coming home they left for two
three four years
those
that's the way it works
your boys are not going to be
they're not their lives aren't going to
be ruined if you're not there at every
ball game
and i'll tell you there's actually
if you do that your sons
will learn the meaning
of duty and sacrifice more than a normal
kid would
so
so pay attention to that too
again all that being said
this is something that only you can make
the call on because you're you can
analyze the details of the situation and
you know what if your wife works a war
your wife works your dog wife doesn't
work that makes a big deal
if your wife works
and you're gone all the time that's a
problem now who's raising your kids so
you got to pay attention to that if you
if you both work but you both work
normal jobs now you're home and you're
doing you're you know you're there
enough
so just weigh these things out but
i would i would get the details
and then make a decision and you know
what no matter what decision you make
it's the right decision how's that
that's pretty simple you're if you make
a decision and you're gonna go on the
tactical team cool
if you don't cool you're still doing
federal law enforcement awesome
keeping the keeping the monsters at bay
yeah the thing that helped me a lot that
you explained early on is to tell them
why you tell people why you're doing
what you're doing you know the team and
in this case the family or whatever in
this specific case probably your wife
yeah
so if you're feeling that because i did
i did the the feeling of like oh i i
feel like i'm not being as loyal to my
family because i'm like focusing on work
yeah kind of thing so i'll get that from
time to time you know especially if i'm
like super focused and it's like dang i
didn't think about my kids or family all
day today you know i'll have that little
thing whatever i dig yeah
and i used to go like four months
without thinking about my family i'm
such a
horrible well it's a sliding scale so
you know um but
i do know that the more i communicate
with my wife and be like hey i have to
go here and this is what i'm gonna i'm
gonna really try to focus on this you
know this week you know so hey a video
this week
sure
and you know i i'm really busy uh yeah
i'll be so i might not be here for this
and this and you know like i might miss
this you know and just lay it all out
you know why you're doing it you know
how you always say and
a lot of the times your loyalty will be
demonstrated demonstrated with that you
know like it's like hey i'm doing my my
job it's the time requirements are a
little bit more or whatever like i want
you to know like what can i can we do
anything can we adjust anything to make
it better for everybody or whatever
you're 100 right and and actually to
take that one step further including
your wife into the decision making
process where you're like hey listen hon
yeah this if i do this job it's going to
be more but hey it's going to be super
rewarding to me
and sometimes that's enough you know you
tell your wife this can be super
rewarding for me because i'm going to be
able to go and kill bad guys which is or
protect innocent people which is what i
want to do that's what i signed up for
and i'm going to be able to do it in a
in a more complete way and there's a
chance your wife says you know what
i know that's what you're born to do go
do it or she might say listen you've
done that already
you know let's focus on the family and
you be cool yeah those are both good
decisions yeah we're in a win-win
situation here yeah that's the bottom
line dude
yeah
next question jacob i'm 19 and my in my
first year of college ever since i was
12 i've dreamed about being a marine or
seal
i plan on joining up after college but i
just got diagnosed with epilepsy i only
have seizures in my sleep so i never
noticed them
i always thought of serving in the
military as a way
that i would prove to myself that i was
a man
and that it would give my life a purpose
now i don't know what to do i hate the
idea of living some comfortable life
where i have a cozy nine-to-five job
that i only do for the money i want
something hard and meaningful what
should i do
there's an infinite number of options
that you have so
you need to just pick one of those
options find a new career of
that you think looks cool and then go
get after it and you got to figure you
want to you don't want a nine-to-five
job cold there's all kinds of jobs that
aren't nine-to-five you know whether
it's construction management
construction or gas oil or some kind of
public safety there's all kinds of
things i don't know if you can be a
firefighter i don't know if you can be a
cop if you have epilepsy i'm not sure
but there's all kinds of different jobs
and careers
and there's jobs that are hard
and there's jobs that are incredibly
meaningful to our economy here
and the more you help our economy here
the more you help us have a positive
influence in the world so
go and figure out what job you want to
do and go crush it
and go
you know build an empire and make a ton
of money and then if you want to great
then you can support some veterans
causes and you can give back that way
so so that's cool there's there's
it's always impressive to me we work
with all kinds of different companies
at echelon front
it's always so impressive to me
when i meet people from every possible
industry that you can imagine and
they're completely
into their job
they are so into their job
they're fighting world war nine like
they're that into it
you know they're running intel they're
running operations they're driving down
every dollar matters everything that
they're doing they're so into it and
it's awesome
and and this is everything this is every
different industry i see people like
that now not every person in every
industry is like that
but
if you find something that you're
interested in and you jump in there
and that's going to be your vocation
right now there's another part to this
that
is kind of
i guess like
in your head or whatever
and that's like some kind of hard living
that's not that's not very difficult to
come up with right go start training jiu
jitsu go start training some boxing go
start wrestling go do muay thai go start
shooting go start lifting and seeing how
strong you can get and see how powerful
you can get
go learn to hunt and learn to hike and
learn to play guitar and learn just
learn a bunch of stuff
become a force to be reckoned with
and
you know the bottom line is being a seal
or being a marine does not prove that
you are a man
there are plenty of losers
in both of those organizations
and so don't you don't need some label
to make you a man
that's not what makes you a man
be your own man
go out and
conquer your part of the world
next question
two questions
i recently attended an assessment for
retraining let's say one more thing
sorry no man when things like this
happen like when something happens to me
this is you want to hear my weird
superstitious um
view of the world
sure
it's sort of it's sort of reminiscent of
everything happens for a reason you've
heard that everyone's heard that for me
something like this
when something like this happens to me
when something happens in my life that i
didn't want to have happen or i didn't
expect to happen i get an unpleasant
surprise
i look at it and assess it like okay
this is
this is happening so that's something
else this is trying to prevent something
else from happening to me that i would
have been
really catastrophic i hurt my knee the
other day doing jiu jitsu
doing wrestling
and
i you know on my way driving home i'm
like you know what
this is preventing me
from
wrecking my shoulder
in two weeks or the next night i was
probably gonna wreck my shoulder which
is which is you know
a catastrophic injury on my shoulder
that's what was about to happen to me
and
the powers that be
knew the only way to get me off the map
was to hurt my knee bad enough that it
pulled me off the map for
for a couple weeks so boom there you go
here you go jocko you're welcome yeah so
something like this
this is an indicator as far as i'm
concerned you have some bigger and
better thing that you need to do
something hey it wasn't this that's cool
accept it like right on say thank you
because there's people that
they they it's not epilepsy that they
have they have something that
debilitates them from doing
even things that you are capable of
doing so be stoked
that this delivery came
from wherever it comes from whatever
it is that you believe in
that this this this
guy this happened
because it's it's putting you on the
path i guess that's what i'm saying it's
putting you on the path
so who knows what you're supposed to do
but you're supposed to do something
because you're not supposed to be a seal
you're not supposed to be a marine if
you were supposed to be that that would
happen it didn't happen that's not a bad
thing that means there's some other door
it's going to open up big yeah
so that's the way i i always look at
injuries like that yeah that's the most
positive way i can look at injuries is
hey
i was going to
whatever i was gonna
like i was gonna rip apart triple threat
on my knee
in four days so i just got a little ding
to pull me off the mat so that doesn't
happen yeah
oh i needed rest
here's what you get boom you're gonna
get this
yeah i'll have those thoughts do
something yes like it's kind of like oh
i'm safe from injury because i'm already
injured kind of thing yeah that really
it's a weird feeling yeah but that is
true and yeah and kind of like a lot of
times too and this is so good that that
guy this guy
is he knows already i want to do
something hard on me
man
how did he say how old he was 19 19. man
19 i didn't hit him
yeah he's not he's already on the path
but he's totally on the path and you
know he's just discovering what doors he
wants to you know what doors are open
what doors are closed whatever you know
and he's just got man 19
nah i didn't have no direction did it
did i ever have the thought of hey yeah
i want to do something hard and
meaningful did i ever have that thought
hmm
no i did not have that thought ever
lifting weights or something like this
but yeah man that's good so yeah i think
he's in the game yeah
yeah there's no there's no label that
makes you a man you do you check and
you're doing a good job so far evidently
all right next question two questions i
recently attended assessment for
retraining into the combat control
career field i'm active duty for air
force in a different career field
and rang the bell
during water confidence training how do
i live with my decision and move forward
yeah and then you see there's two
there's two questions that are basically
the same question so that was part a and
this is part b
i do read dord deal okay drop on request
gotcha raring the bell same thing so i
uh dr from buds class 303 i went went on
to be a sar chorus chordsman star
swimmer star swimmer corman so he was a
he was a rescue swimmer okay but it's ta
but it's taken until recently to regain
the desire to live
and even strive to work out again
what can you do
when you realize a life path you've
chosen was not only wrong but you never
feel like you found a new path
to me this this question both these
questions are kind of similar to the
previous one right and
like i can tell you being a being a seal
or being a combat controller is not the
be-all end-all
and the bottom line is it wasn't for you
it wasn't for you it wasn't even either
one of you guys it just wasn't for you
and the the fact of the matter is it's
not for most people it's not normal
there's an 80 attrition rate of buds
most people quit good people i was down
there the other day
and i was talking one of my buddies that
runs
runs it runs the he's a civilian but
he's one of the civilians that works
there but he was
we were talking about
you know what it about buds
and i forget what even led into it but
he pointed at the you know when you when
you quit blood you put your helmet by
the bell
and so as more and more people quit
more and more helmets will end up and
there'll be hundreds of helmets lined up
and
he's like you see those helmets right
there and i'm like yeah he goes every
single one of those kids was a stud
and when i went through it wasn't quite
like that because not everyone that was
showing up at buds in the 90s
was a stud
they weren't because we didn't know what
was happening we didn't know
we didn't know how to do a pull-up
workout we couldn't look online
and see a program on how to get better
at rope climbs we didn't know that you
had to swim with fins we didn't know
i didn't know what i didn't know
anything when i showed up at the buds
so
these kids now they know everything and
so what do they do they prepare all of
them at a minimum i would say the
minimum guy prepared now is probably
prepared at least as good as the most
prepared guy actually that's probably
that's probably inaccurate
i bet you the minim the least prepared
guy entering buds right now
is probably still more prepared than the
most prepared guy that went to buds when
i went through
now
so so my point in saying that is most of
those people that are studs quit
most of those people that join the navy
that sign on a dotted line and commit
six years of their life
because there's nothing more they want
to do than be a seal and most of them
don't make it through
so it's not for everyone
and
then you know what you you one guy in
the air force one guy in the navy you
did your job you did what you're
supposed to do corman whatever your
normal career field was in the air force
and you served your country
and you did what the country needed you
to do the country needs you to do
whatever job you did the country needed
you to do that job so thank you for your
service and now you go and find
something else you go and find a new
mission
and the same things here like you you
want to get better with your life
so what do you do you work and you build
and you study and you get an awesome
physical condition and you train jiu
jitsu and you become a doctor or a
firefighter or emt or a cop and there's
whichever way that you figure out that
you can serve you become a business
person you go and work construction
whatever it is that you do
you go and do it you do it hard and you
don't get caught up in a title right
so
this is another thing this kind of
reflects back to what we were talking
about earlier
seals don't care that you weren't a seal
you know like it's not like seals are
walking around going oh this person
wasn't a seal i don't respect them this
person wasn't a ceo i don't respect them
we don't care it's a vocation it's a job
so you're not i don't look down on
people that weren't seals
it's just that was my job you had a
different job right
it's it's like it's like jiu jitsu i
don't look down on people that don't
train jiu jitsu
i look at him like hey you should
because that's a choice
but
let me rephrase that i don't look down
on people that i can beat in jiu jitsu
because i know for a fact all it is is
that i've been training longer than them
and once they train longer than me
they'll be able to beat me that's the
way it works
so
people that were in the single teams
aren't looking down on you because you
weren't they don't care they're not
thinking about it
so
when i meet a cop when i meet a
firefighter when i meet a business
person i respect what they're doing with
their life if they're getting after it i
don't care what arena it's in man i know
some i i'm so lucky right now working at
ashland front we meet people that are
just
just awesome humans that are crushing
their field
and if they were in the seal teams
they'd be crushing that field but they
didn't they went to what they went and
did what they did
they went in the finance world they went
in the construction world they went in
the gas oil business whatever they did
they did and they're getting after it
so that's what you need to do
you quit in the past you rang the bell
no one cares
unless you quit now
so get up
go find a new mission and get after it
man get after it
next question
you've been unfairly wronged by a
brother
objectively
you aren't getting the full apology that
you expected
the beef is over now and he treats you
well but how do you psychologically
reframe and kill that lingering
resentment
unfairly wronged by a brother
interesting
brothers don't wrong brothers we'll
start with that so this dude wasn't
actually a bro a brother might have been
a bro but he wasn't a brother
make a little distinction there has that
distinction ever been made before i
don't think on this
platform and then i'm making it cool
there's like hey this guy's my bro it's
all good and then there's like this
guy's my brother
my brother is not gonna wrong me
my bro might
but my brother's not gonna wrong me
so
that so if it happens some guy
like i said if somebody that you
consider your brother wrongs you then
they'd clearly you
you overestimated their
commitment
here's what's gonna happen with me
number one it's noted
noted
that's my that's my ultimate
that's my ultimate
satisfaction
right when i know when it's when i note
something yeah oh it's like oh this is
the kind of person he is noted right now
i got him man now i got this person
marked
so
trust is not going to be reestablished
for a long long time if ever
right
i'm not going to
like this person clearly
but here's the deal all that
mistrust and all that dislike and all
that
is going to be internal i'm gonna keep
it inside
because you know what i'm gonna have
those inside i'm gonna harbor that i'm
gonna harbor those things even this
resentment i'm gonna harbor it because i
can't i can't just make it go wait you
you wronged me it's going to be there
yeah
but you know what i'm a professional
externally i'm a professional
even if we're not in a business even if
it's just like hair i i trained jiu
jitsu with this guy right i'm a
professional
so i'm not going to let his little
maneuvers get me externally worked up
about it it's not happening you don't
get control my emotions like that
externally you might control them inside
but i won't let you see that ever
so
i'm a professional i'm normal face
that's where i'm coming at you from just
normal face hey all good oh yeah
and you know what's interesting
this behavior so when you screw me over
and then i just go okay check noted
and then
i don't give you a reason to like hate
me
and then you kind of owe me
yeah you know what i mean
so there's that and there's a there's a
fine line like if you screw me over and
then
i just allow it to happen and it was a
it was a uh a legitimate violation well
then there might be have to be
repercussions right it sounds like this
did not warrant repercussions
because you know there's certain
situations if somebody
wrongs you in certain ways there has to
be repercussions
to me normally most of the time the
repercussions and the best revenge that
you can take is is to ignore and
outperform and be successful and rock on
and forget about them and
forget they even existed that to me is
the best possible way to go
because why would you let somebody
interfere why would you commit any time
effort resources to revenge
when i would the better thing to do is
commit those time resources to energy to
success to winning yeah i'm gonna do
that
but if this merits some sort of
repercussions okay then those get
carried out
and if those get carried out well then
we're
we're kind of settled but
he says you didn't get the full apology
you expected it's like okay i mean hey
guess what
people are arrogant yeah that's the way
it is they don't think the guy didn't
even think he did anything wrong most
likely he's not even apologizing for it
barely
so
that's what i do i'm just gonna keep it
professional i'm gonna you're gonna be
subconsciously indebted to me whether
you know it or not yeah
you probably know it you'll probably
feel it because i'm just gonna be like
okay cool yeah
we'll move on
but ant-man you know the thing is this
sort of goes back to that other
kind of topic today like this guy isn't
going around thinking about you yeah so
why are you thinking about him let's
move on man
let's move forward
yeah that seems like a big part of it
right like that seems like he was
he says you aren't you aren't getting
the full apology you know i remember on
that seinfeld that apology dude i was
talking to someone
i was talking to someone like like the
apology i was talking to someone that we
both know
who's
we'll say
a
a public figure sure
and this individual was reading youtube
comments okay and getting legitimately
like emotionally distraught about the
whole thing yeah
and was was trying to talk to me about
it and like
i said man i literally do not care
i'm like i do not care like this is no
factor you don't need to warn me
you don't need to tell me
you know what i need to look out for
like i literally don't care yeah i mean
if someone writes a good youtube comment
good it's funny that's great if they
write a mean one cool i think those are
funny too yeah i'm not i'm not worried
about it the person that wrote the
youtube comment isn't thinking about me
yeah you know they're not trying they're
not they're not reviewing it again yeah
they're writing it again and you know
like they don't care
i'm not getting all caught up in this
stuff don't get caught up in these petty
things you know i did that
we talked about this on the podcast of
of
of the black belt the black belt doesn't
care about things that don't matter you
can grab the black belt's
shoulder
it was ghee and he doesn't care because
he knows that doesn't mean anything
there's no there's no there's no factor
so you wanna that's that's what you
wanna do you wanna you don't wanna care
about things that don't matter don't
invest your time and energy things don't
matter the guy wronged you cool noted
you know that he's kind of kind of a uh
a devious dude you know that it's noted
cool move on yeah no i'm not worried
about it am i going to put my trust in
me again no but that's cool because i
know other people to trust yeah
let's not get wrapped around these
little things man let's let's let's
let's let's let's rise above we'll get
some black flag going here let's rise
above i still wonder what kind of
apology i totally cut you off so sorry
about it yeah yeah no it was a seinfeld
thing it didn't matter the
but i'm wondering what
at the same time what you're saying i
agree
but
i do wonder what kind of apology he got
you know because he didn't get the full
apology yeah partial yeah so while
partial apology that can come in many
forms yeah it's probably the most common
form of a partial apology has a bud on
it yes yeah yeah that was 100 you know
i'm sorry you know i'm sorry we didn't
swing by and pick the other up the other
night but i just didn't even know that
you wanted to come yeah yeah yeah kind
of like you it was my fault i'm sorry
but yeah it was partially your fault
kind of thing and then there's the other
one that's like i'm sorry you felt that
way you know you know that one where
it's like hey i'm sorry you felt that i
was attacking you you know but you know
i didn't mean to kind of thing where
it's kind of like hey
you're because the person doesn't want
an apology for necessarily the actual
words you said it was it was like what
you did
like you attacked me with whatever you
said you know kind of thing so you can't
just say hey i can't i'm sorry you
forgot that that's right isn't it i'm
sorry that you felt that way yeah you
know that is a pretty backhanded sort of
yeah same thing but the with the butt
well the when you say butt i i'm sorry
but you know i didn't know that's kind
of like i'm sorry but i'm not fully like
yeah that's the same way that's the same
with extreme ownership yeah that's when
people say
you know look i'm in charge of the team
and this was definitely i'm in charge of
the team when i'm in charge then then
when things go wrong it's my fault
but i'll tell you what
as soon as i hear that i'm always
thinking like you're not sorry brad yeah
sorry yeah and my wife from time to time
there are no excuses
yeah there's no if you think about it
when you get somebody that actually
believes in extreme ownership there
isn't there are no buts on anything that
they say and strangely i mean kind of i
guess coincident not coincidental
your old daughter will not allow you to
make an excuse
my nine-year-old daughter she will call
you out if you throw a butt or you say
well
i didn't know when we had to be there oh
so
you're not taking ownership yeah
yes
it makes yeah totally makes sense and if
you it's strangely like if you do it
without the butt you know when you do it
just full speed even if in your head you
believe but i mean let's face it man you
had it coming to you you kind of think
just yeah just keep it because that's
not what you're doing when you apologize
that's that's separate from the apology
you know it's like you're including this
stuff unwarranted stuff with your
apology don't do that give a good
apology and make it is the worst thing
is is it's so obvious and it makes
everyone so mad oh yeah the receiving
end of that is so mad
and you think that it's you think that
it's improving your position yeah
because you're expired look look hey
echo i'm really sorry that you showed up
to record and i wasn't there and i
didn't let you know
but
but i didn't really i didn't remember
texting you or whatever like like but
you know you should have told me that
you were heading that's that's the way i
would but you should have told me that
we were definitely recording because you
didn't really get back to me yeah like
why would i say that yeah all i'm doing
is you know what's funny is people
always tweet me when a sports coach
they tweet me when a sports coach either
takes ownership or doesn't overtly yes
not overtly because some guy some sports
coaches say hey look i'm the coach i
made some bad calls out there we're
gonna get back in the drawing room i'm
gonna get this thing fixed and everyone
goes man this guy's awesome and it's
just so funny everyone says this guy is
awesome he's taking ownership yeah even
people that aren't even people will
retweet something that they people
aren't saying
he's taking extreme ownership someone
will say oh it's good to see a coach
taking full responsibility or whatever
they'll use their own word for it right
and then some other knucklehead
we'll we'll say
you know i am the coach and i am
responsible for the team but if i got
players that aren't going to put out
during the first quarter but you know
yeah i'm not the one on the field yeah
you know you you got to carry out
totally embarrassing and everyone says
hey you might want to learn how to take
ownership yeah and that's what people so
it's so obvious and yet we still do it
we still throw out the butts we still
want to clarify our position
yeah don't clarify your position
say sorry take ownership that's it my
wife will watch these uh
what do you call it the housewives one
not the show like the reality show ones
you know the whatever housewives of
wherever and men riddled i think that's
why she watches it just to see the train
wreck i think that's what i think is my
suspicion but men yeah they they're all
arguing with each other and then
you know they're crying and then one
will say they'll just they'll say the
perfect example of the non-apology you
know every single time yeah man it's
like it hurts your heart to watch but
you kind of like you kind of dig it
i
i wonder if
this is because this is what happened
with this guy i just i just figured it
out right now i really don't know but
this is what i think happens oh okay
theoretical yeah there was a there was a
girl guy relationship there was a what a
girl guy relationship okay you know
boyfriend girlfriend scenario you know
maybe this guy got drunk
the bro the brother bro whatever
got drunk maybe hit on the girl maybe
something happened maybe something did
it
oh and then it was like hey man sorry
about what i did with christine last
night i was super hammered yes but i was
super hammered yeah exactly right and
that's a big one that's a big butt in
the apology you know but you know we all
had
i remember some once that time someone
did i won't go into it doesn't matter
but it's a big one yeah it's a big deal
or it's a big common one got wronged by
a brother
bro no it was my like
parent's friend okay this lady and she
like she was talking
she was talking about my mom to my
dad and i was there they're hammered or
whatever like some you know thing and
she's like totally talking i think
we're gonna talk about this but i'm
gonna do it i'm gonna do it
so i'm like whatever i'm like a t i'm
maybe 15 16 years old maybe maybe 13 i
don't know whatever but you know a
teenager i wasn't like a three-year-old
you know
so i heard and i knew what she was
talking about it was it was rude it was
unclear it's unsad
as we say and so i'm like cool i go home
and i tell my mom straight up so my
mom's like oh okay you know tells me dad
blah blah blah my dad tells the lady and
the lady of course is all like oh no you
know like i did this and you know so she
comes to me and she says sorry
right like sorry for this or but we had
you know we had a lot to drink or
whatever and all this stuff and i
remember feeling that like how is it
like how does this make it better you
know when you're like but we had so i'm
thinking and i didn't know anything
about drinking i i don't know what it
made you sort of do i didn't really
know at that time so to me it was like
wait so wait when you drink like you can
do that kind of stuff or what like
what's the the deal and the
apology just basically bounced off me
like bullets off of superman or
something yeah no apology don't put the
butts on those things yes so that's what
happened with this guy that's what i
think possible
but it is his responsibility like you
said to be like hey i can't hold on to
this thing you know like what do you say
how do you psychologically reframe it
and kill that lingering resentment the
thing is it's like a scar you have to
he's like keeping it a wound yeah he's
curious
yeah and you got to be like that's just
a scar it's like sure our relationship
is different now it's a scar now but man
i got more important things to think
about or do whatever
yeah if you can pull that that off you'd
be good move on
next question hello and thank you sir
i'm an inner city math teacher an og
hardcore kid
i successfully approached my students as
a team that i am the leader of how do i
discipline some of my key players and at
the same time boost or at least not
lower
morale
awesome well that's cool
i would say this if you got kids in the
classroom and you got key players in the
classroom
do what i always say to do to people
put them in charge of stuff man
put them in charge put these kids in
charge of things in the class not just
dumb stuff either not just clean up
not just sweeping the floor but some
legitimate stuff
like hey i want you to come up with a
lesson plan for tomorrow here's the book
that we're looking at here's the pages i
want you to talk about dang
i want you to lead the discussion that
we're going to have in class hey i want
you to go over how you solve this math
problems tomorrow
you got you got some of the problems
wrong on the test
i want to teach them to you and i want
you to teach the class
because
obviously i didn't do a good job maybe
you can do a better job than me
and you know what
you you're kind of you're kind of loud
let's put that to use i know people
listen to you here's another thing kid
the kids look look at you and they look
up to you
let's use that let's try and get kids
moving in the right direction
so that's what i would do in a situation
like this
if someone's actually getting in trouble
i wouldn't you don't do this you don't
do what i'm talking about because
they're in trouble right that's a little
bit you can't say you're in trouble so
you're gonna have to teach class
tomorrow no no that doesn't work
you say you say hey you let that
whatever they got punished for you use
you know your punishment that could be
something like taking out trash
but
you don't want to throw leadership at
someone when they get in trouble
occasionally you can do it occasionally
you can be like okay
you know what you're in charge of the
platoon for this week or for these four
days of admin
and all of a sudden yeah you realize oh
you gotta come in at five o'clock in the
morning oh you gotta stay until 1800 at
night oh you got these reports too oh
yeah it's like all these things that you
didn't think about that's what you got
to do
and when you get off that restriction
and you get out of that role you realize
hey i have a little respect for the boss
because i realize what the boss is going
through so that's what i would do have
some fun with this put the kids in
charge of stuff give them little
assignments make them get up make them
turn them into leaders
check
we think one more
one more
what do you do when you fail and how do
you handle it
what do you do when you fail
you know recently
we reviewed
that us army field manual
on here from
like world war ii
era and it says in that manual it says
other than death
all failure is psychological
other than death all failure is
psychological think about that
just just just think about that this
failure this upset this
this catastrophe
if you aren't dead
then it's just psychological
it's in your head
now
this does not mean that you won't
lose some battles because you will we
all will
but
it does mean that
as long as you don't surrender as long
as you don't give up as long as you
don't quit then you haven't failed
just means you've made a
a temporary tactical retreat means
you've made a a brief withdrawal
so that you can regroup
and re-attack
so
as far as i'm concerned if you get beat
unless you're dead you are not defeated
and you have not failed
what you've done is you've learned
you've
you've gained experience
and you're still alive
and you have
memories to make
so get up
and go get after it
and i think that's
all i've got for tonight so echo charles
yes
speaking of
getting after it sure
getting after it can you
help us in that category yes so we are
on the path part of that part of that
path like we always say is jiu-jitsu
it's funny how like you'll say dude like
when you suggest someone to to or your
suggestion for someone to like move on
or to like
you know get out of a rut or whatever
you always say jujitsu yes and rightly
so yes
it all
it's one of those things men where i
i am not a psychologist
i know you know that but i think that
it'll cure
various levels of depression
for real
hey
i've taken a lot of flack over that yeah
i've taken a lot of flack over that i
think
joe rogan
sure
when i was on his you know we were
basically saying like work out you know
feel better and everyone got all mad
right but the funny thing is tim ferriss
who has actually gone through that kind
of depression will tell you the exact
same thing yeah
so
yeah
workout workout end
jiu-jitsu for sure yeah it's crazy with
you know why i'd say jiu jitsu even more
than just like a regular workout
whatever that even means but um is
because
you have a challenge that's a little bit
more obviously like you against like an
obvious challenge you know you against
the person there's that okay and then
there's the physical part of it of
course like the workout part of it which
is
one of the best workouts like if i
wanted to like lose
30 pounds right first i don't know
whatever if i want to lose 30 pounds
like bad pounds right so i you know
and
right now as of right now there's no way
i would do like a a weight loss workout
yeah i would just do regular weight
lifting and i would just do more
jiu-jitsu yeah that's it 100 like why
would you so i'm crazy i mean jiu-jitsu
is such a good workout
yeah why would you work out muscles that
you didn't know you had your whole body
too yeah by the way whole body yeah even
your jaw muscles yep yeah
yeah oh yeah everything especially you
with the jaw muscles because you're
spending a lot of time on the corner of
the bat talking
strange or coincidentally that's another
part of it is what i was about to say
social aspect
for you for everybody
yeah for you too and have a little
conversation oh yeah post training yeah
even like between rounds whatever it's
like you're doing it and sure you can do
that at the gym kind of but it's
different you know what it's way
different people want to talk before
training i protest that you know how i
protest it i start to dark start the
clock
okay the five minute rounds are on you
guys are rolling people enough of this
shitty chatter here's how prevalent
the social element is geez look it's you
no no and you'll agree with it because
it happens with you too so you ever like
shake and kiss clock started clock
started you shake hands with the person
and then you just sneak in one question
to the person like socially no
not all the time because like you know
you remember like i'll do it with greg
i'll do
i will joke about that oh like we'll
talk about our day like andy and i will
joke about yeah yeah like beep clock
starts and it's like
uh how's work today dude yeah yeah yeah
but that happens because basically what
it means is neither one of us feels like
training yeah yeah and so we'll just
laugh and then we'll train right because
we won't we won't actually have a
conversation right but see how you
know that it's a it is a thing it's a
thing so much that you make jokes about
it yes it is that's how social it is you
know and man it's like i just gotta time
my belt and adjust my key and put my
knee pads back up and you know what i
mean yeah there's another stalling
tactics yeah
not very social but yeah it's stalling
for sure um but
so there's a lot of benefits to this
thing that we call
anyway that was a side note anyway when
you're doing ggs of course you need a
ghee because you're doing ghee and no
ghee so when you get your kiwis we're
getting we're getting the best keys are
we getting the junkies keys we're
getting the best keys correct oh yeah
big time anyway the best keys are origin
geez you get them at origin maine.com
dot com the all kinds of stuff
all kinds of clothes including jeans
yes
which you know what even like not
everyone does jiu-jitsu not everyone
does gijijitsu but everyone does have
genes now let me ask you the same
question you asked me what kind of genes
are we getting best kind not the junkies
not the junk would you say junkist
junkist yeah that's not even a word yes
it is
it is the junkiest kind it is
if something is junk oh you know what
it's just another one of those subtle
differences in in remember how i told
you in hawaii they're like subtle
differences in words they're only small
they're pretty much the same but they're
so different one of them that is one of
them like junk is that that's a little
pigeon
yeah there's a little pigeon like it
would be junkiest
right not junkies exactly right so junk
is the same as junkie like it's this
it's like in the mainland you say junkie
like it's it's more of a what do you
call it like not a verb
oh yeah like that that that hamburger is
real is a real junky right so junk on
the mainland the word junk is a noun
it's a junk it's a piece of junk it's
a pile of junk it's a noun
in
hawaii it's a it's an adjective like
it's junk like that's a way of
describing it well
that was noun no
see it sounded like a noun to you
because you're from the mainland if you
say john that's why you can have words
like it's junker
like way more junk
way more jungle okay we don't want the
junk because there's such thing as junk
junker and junkist in hawaii in here
it's like no it's just junk it's either
junk or it's like nut junk you know kind
of thing because it's a noun see i'm
saying like i said these differences are
subtle gotta follow though yeah i know
because i thought of like if you went if
i said hey what's that stuff on the side
of your house over there echo you'd be
like oh that's just junk right a pilot
that's junk and i get what you mean by
that it's an old lawn chair it's an old
weed whacker that doesn't work anymore
right yeah there's a couple
stuffed animals that no one wants
anymore that's junk yes but what you're
saying is
hey how's that car that you just bought
yeah how does it work how is it is that
thing
dope is it dope and you're like no no
it's junk how was that movie last night
kind of junk
yeah okay so
in regards to jeans you don't want the
junk jeans or in your case the junkie or
junkiest jeans junkist is what you said
correct that's the whole the kawaii
version hawaii yes that's how um
nonetheless yeah you want the best ones
get the origin genes and whatever other
clothes and don't forget about
supplements too supplements joint
warfare krill oil discipline discipline
go
discipline go for when you need a little
kick and and it's interesting you and i
have both morphed to a situation where
discipline
the drink
is just the normal that's just part of
the world that's just part of it yeah i
am now drinking and this is the thing
about discipline
it doesn't have
480 grams of or 480 milligrams of
caffeine yeah in fact it has 15 grams
per scoop this is not the crazy
stimulant that's like
let's face it jiu-jitsu
you don't want to be all amped up on
caffeine going into jiu-jitsu class
negative no that's why
discipline is so good pre-roll
yep so
that's what i've figured out now because
if you have iced tea which i used to
drink a lot of iced tea
drink choco white tea right you you just
drink that stuff right like think of
when you were a kid oh and have some
iced tea that had caffeine in it right
you weren't freaking out
that has way more caffeine than
discipline so what i'm saying is
discipline is now just sort of a
just a day long like an all day i must
have had
i must have had five bottles of
discipline today okay okay yeah that's
that's the whole day because i'm sitting
there drinking it
you know i'm working
yeah i'm writing i'm editing
would you switch
it all right let's face it like
writing and editing sometimes is a real
chore yeah mental chore not fun yeah so
you got to get in the game yeah that's
why i've been drinking a lot of been
disciplined lately
a lot of writing a lot of mental thought
yeah
so anyways you don't know the mega mix
for jiu-jitsu is
discipline
okay water
you can actually add like a little like
a maybe like a third
cup whatever the third of your mix total
of like a cranberry juice
or like uh you can squeeze lemon juice
in there or something okay water lemon
juice
discipline
and on it has these like minerals and
electrolytes mix one scoop of that boom
that's the jiu-jitsu mega mix there you
go it'll bring you through go to do two
scoops of discipline three if you want
to get nuts
you gotta add more water you know and
then you got that situation going or
whatever there's been times where i've
made discipline shots
okay like i know like okay
okay you know what i'm i'm heading to
jiu jitsu
i'm gonna be there in three minutes oh
yeah yeah i'm just gonna mix up a little
shot it's got three scoops and it's it's
like a shot
yeah so i've done that before but that's
also why i made discipline go yeah
because discipline glow is for those
situations where you don't want to drink
a bunch but you just want that hitter
yeah but the go the pill that that takes
longer though right because it's not
instant yeah the instance that's where i
take it like i don't know half an hour
40 minutes prior to yeah event situation
yeah evolution it's like yeah they have
luch
mine i feel like is or it is straight up
it's like a routine you know how like
you sort of have a routine yes you know
some people do i got some routines yeah
and um
yeah the protocol comes into play like
this you go boom okay i got jujitsu at x
x time right i leave the house at x time
minus whatever
i drink the mega mix
x time minus whatever minus you know
another 10 minutes so it's like the the
the amount of time it takes to mix it up
just tell everyone when to drink it if
they're gonna roll
or do something active oh
the thing is i don't wanna say 40
minutes you say half an hour
40 minutes half an hour i'm saying 40
minutes i'll drink mine as i'd leave the
house so i'll have my coffee how long
it's take to get here
between 15 and 20 minutes okay so but
you don't need it to kick in right when
you get here because you're gonna be
chat with people for the first half hour
correct yes yeah well it's one of those
things it's not like there's this little
teeny tiny window of it working but once
it's in the in the system right you're
rolling you know oh yeah i you don't
even really like feel it like
wear off or nothing like a coffee crash
or nothing like that so i don't know i
just do it that way that's been and it's
worth like man i'll i won't not do it
that way yeah
uh also don't forget about milk which is
if you need extra protein which you do
you can get it from milk or if you just
want a straight straight-up dessert you
just have dessert and if you don't think
the strawberry mulk tastes like dessert
you're wrong the strawberry mulk is
dessert
get some and some of the other ones i've
just had so much of them i'm just really
stoked on a strawberry right now mint
you know what it was your go-to peanut
butter or is it mint mint but all the
interchange for variety whatever that
straw everyone came in thanks brian for
that by the way so it's like okay you
know strawberry slayer
there's a lot of hype yeah it's
strawberry cool i'm not the hugest um
like i like i like the strawberry i like
it yeah but
when there's chocolate like why would
you do strawberry you know if you have
chocolate or whatever so i'm like but
whatever let's do it
the
strawberry with is so i'll mix it up
boom the same deal i didn't want to like
add extra stuff in there i just i wanted
the raw deal so i had regular milk and
strawberry molk yeah see what the hype's
all about surprisingly surprisingly good
meaning and i don't you know that's a
general term surprisingly good or
whatever to me
the strawberry milk tastes
closer to an actual strawberry milkshake
the only difference that i could detect
is that it's not as like overtly sweet
as like one from like a you know like
you get a strawberry milkshake from a
place yeah you know it just wasn't as
sweet as that that's it put a little put
another half a scoop in there and you'll
be in the zone that's what i thought
yeah
and that's what i'm telling you what so
i
i implemented the that hater the real
litmus test
right so i what do you call it enlist
the kids yeah and have them sit down i
was like all right here this is
strawberry mulk
have some just a little thing so here's
how you do it you don't say is it good
is it not good because if they're not
you want more you don't even ask that
you just wait
so because if you ask hey is it good or
not good if they're old enough they'll
tell you what you want to hear they'll
be like yeah good then they'll go play
or they won't be into the test at all
which typically they're not and they'll
just be like no it's junk therefore you
know in their mind he won't give me
anymore or whatever you know you just
don't get an action action uh an
accurate reading so what you do is here
you can have some of this that's it so
they tasted it both of them wanted more
both of them
yeah that's what it is really good stuff
uh so and also don't forget you got
warrior kid milk that comes in
strawberry and chocolate as well and
it's
it's like a legitimately good for your
children
so get it for him oh yeah
also chocolate tea yes chocolate has
some tea it's called choco white tea
yeah
and it just is like drinking goodness
that's what it is like drinking victory
drinking tastes like it tastes like
victory and it's just goodness got
antioxidants gets you a little gets you
a little kicker
certified organic tube by the way yeah
yeah so that's that anyway really cool
orgymayne.com forgot to say that yes
also draco has his own store jocko store
so you go to jacostore.com this is where
you can get your discipline equals
freedom shirts hoodies
lightweight and heavyweight
hats
you know anyway hats
no you know no heavyweight hats um you
know but you do have those trucker hats
with what do you call it snap back
or flex fit so some options there
anyway any way you want to represent the
path you can get something there rash
cards as well jiu-jitsu or whatever
you're doing boom you can get one of
those shirt that says good on it that
does not have my head on it which is a
positive thing
moving in a different direction more
subtle direction
i don't necessarily agree because i
think that the one with your head on it
is like that's not very subtle bro no
it's not subtle at all but it it does
like
no they both have their benefits because
look when i wear the good one just just
good like the the people who do say
something they're just kind of like oh
yeah good good they'll just say it you
know but the one with your head they'll
either ask oh who's that on your shirt
like who is that usually it's like i
don't know you know
winston churchill or i don't know you
wear a public figure in there so they're
wondering who is that and why they don't
stay in church
we gotta do that now
that's the first thing that came to mind
i've never seen a winston churchill
t-shirt but i'm glad that we got that
going
or they'll know who you are and they
know that that's what you say and
they'll be like you know what do you
call it the book that when they know and
you know bonafide yes exactly right so i
dig both 100
but nonetheless a lot of cool stuff on
there if you uh
if you like something
get something as they say also subscribe
to the podcast if you haven't already on
itunes and stitcher and wherever you
listen to podcasts because a lot of
places
they're trying to kind of change the
landscape of podcast listening too by
the way oh yeah yeah they want to charge
money or something put it behind the
firewalls
i think it's paywall paywall maybe the
firewall too the firewall the paywall
anyways we're free we're free yeah free
but nonetheless hey it is well you have
to pay you know what you have to pay you
have to listen to this part of the
podcast which you don't actually even
have to do
absolutely it's like one of those little
trays don't forget about the warrior kid
podcast which is also not behind a
paywall it's free for your children if
your kids want to learn how to be on the
path your kids want to learn about
discipline if your kids want to learn
how to handle bullying and trouble in
school and trouble study if they want to
learn to handle all that stuff in life
and if you want to get a little hint too
because you know you need it you can get
some of that warrior kid podcast
yeah that's a good one
also
irish oaks ranch dot com this is where
you can get where a kid's soap yeah
which is not for kids yeah it's actually
it's a jocko soap made by a warrior kid
so it is where you could so called jocko
soap there's another edition called
trooper
soap or is it the trooper bar trooper
soap i think yeah nonetheless it's good
yeah yeah this is good so also yes it'll
help you stay clean it'll make you stay
clean
straight up in a hardcore kind of way
also youtube
if you're interested in the video
version of this podcast of jocko telling
us helping us
advising us do you advise i'm just over
here saying my point of view i guess
more than anything else yeah and then
and then echo makes videos that he's
super proud of and he's all hype about
and he thinks they're super cool so you
can check those out too
yeah
sure yeah there you go nonetheless yes
youtube jaco podcast youtube channel
yeah you have one so yeah we do have our
own youtube channel yes you can sign up
for little announcements
sure that come out notifications i have
that so whenever you post a video
i get a notification yeah and i go oh
cool echo post a video and i watch it
yeah and then i go down and read the
comments
and then someone says echo's looking
jerked
so there's that best comment in the
world but yeah and then psychological
warfare you can get that if you need a
little little assistance during a
challenging moment of weakness if you
press play
on your phone
you can play a little track that will
get you through that moment of weakness
it's on itunes google play mp3 platforms
of all kinds and if you want a visual
representation to help keep you on the
path check out flipsidecanvas.com
where my brother
dakota meyer
is making
art
and just putting it on and he's putting
in the art with layers that's what it is
there you go you just you just coined it
you just made the motto yeah or with
layers we're gonna put some warrior kid
stuff up there for your kids rooms we're
gonna put some warrior kid things up
there so be checking that out
and
if you have anything that you want to
have
on a canvas let dakota meyer know hit
him up on twitter tell him what's going
on tell him what you think he can make
he can make it happen
so there's that also on it on it.com so
this is where you can get your
kettlebells when you're when we
are varying up our workouts need more
kettlebells
you need more
functional fitness type stuff that's
where you get it also like i mentioned
before the the mineral slash electrolyte
mix for the
pre jiu jitsu actually pre-workout too
mega mix
this is where you get it on it dot com
slash jocko
what if you i mean you don't you know
what a pre-workout is it's called a
pre-workout yeah it's like it has like
uh like vasodilators and caffeine and
stuff in it it's mainly for like lifting
or whatever yeah
you can mix that if you work out don't
do metcons on this but if you're just
lifting
for like hypertrophy or whatever and you
like three workouts you mix that in the
megamix so you go pre-workout discipline
two scoops one scoop electrolytes from
on it um lemon juice water
mix that report back ooh that's the mega
mix right there for lifting measure
measure your biceps report back yes yeah
your pump will be out of this world but
before jiu-jitsu don't do the
pre-workout don't do the caffeine before
dude that's my thing anyway on it.com is
where you get it got some books
got some books coming out i got one book
coming out called
way the warrior kid three where there's
a will
uh i think when this podcast out we
might even be live or close to it yeah
so
way the warrior kid three
order it immediately i just
got the numbers prior to walking in here
it's already selling like pretty awesome
so appreciate everyone pre-ordering it
but if you want it order it now so i can
print enough for you because the
publishing company is taco publishing
also
we got way of the warrior kid one
we got way the warrior kid two subtitle
mark's mission way the courtyard way the
warrior kid one subtitle is from wimpy
to warrior the navy seal way teaching
your kids to be on the path and if you
got a little bit younger kid get mikey
in the dragons
mike and the dragons will frame your
child's mind to be able to overcome fear
for the rest of their lives
just a nice little thing to give them
for the rest of your life you don't have
to be afraid of anything yes there you
go there you go child you're welcome
discipline equals freedom field manual
that's how to get after it
the audio of that is on itunes amazon
music google play another mp3 extreme
ownership
and dichotomy leadership both those
books i wrote with my brother leif babin
and we
take the experiences we had in combat
overseas the leadership lessons we
learned and we passed them on to
all of you
also we have echelon front which is our
leadership consultancy
and what we do is we solve problems
through leadership
and if you want to have us come and work
with your company then go to
echelonfront.com if you want to come to
a live experience you can come to the
muster
may 23rd and 24th in chicago sold out
you won't be coming to that one
september 19th and 20th in denver
not sold out yet but it will and
december 4th and 5th in sydney australia
go to extremeownership.com
all of them have sold out all of them
will sell out so get in the game early
ef online
this is our
if you can't make it to the muster but
you want to
get granular with your leadership
capabilities
then go to
efonline.com
and we will take you through
leadership
courses that will pragmatically improve
your leadership skills there's
interactive decisions you have to make
in those courses so check it out
efonline.com and then ef overwatch
if you're a business person and you are
looking for leaders
which is what you need in your company
you need leadership
if you want leadership in your company
we have special operations and combat
aviation veterans
and
we are getting them placed into your
company
so go to ef overwatch if you are looking
for
leaders in your company
and if you want to cruise hard more with
us on the interwebs
twitter instagram and on facebook of
course
i'm at echo charles and jocko is at
jocko willink
what are the three platforms
twitter instagram and
then facebook
definitely
thank you
thank you i didn't i wasn't quite sure
what you said
and thanks to everyone out there that
wears
the cloth of our nation a military
uniform thank you for your sacrifice and
thanks to your families as well who also
sacrifice
to keep the nation safe and thanks to
police law enforcement firefighters
paramedics emts dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol secret service
all first responders for what you do
every day and thanks to your families as
well for supporting you so that you all
can support us
and everyone else out there
remember that life goes by like a summer
day
and you don't have time to get hung up
on failures you don't have time to dwell
in the past and you can't preserve
the memories
perfectly
so make sure you get out there every day
and you make new memories by moving
forward
and getting after it
and until next time
this is echo
and jocko
out